today an executive session may be held
on any bill referred to the committee
but it will not be please note that
there is no physical location for
members of the public to observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming
that all members of the committee and
select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform and the
public has
access to contemporaneously listen and
if necessary participate in this meeting
by the zoom platform
or by telephone all necessary
information
has been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91
a anyone who has a problem accessing
this meeting
should call area code 603-271-3600
or email h c
s at ledge l e g
dot state dot nh dot u s
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
please note that all votes are taken
during this meeting shall be done by
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting
which is a requirement under the right
clerk will call the role representative
expedia
president uh i'm in my parents home um
i'm by myself representative frost
uh president i am home in my kitchen
office
my husband and daughters are home
representative greene
i'm here in concord at llb in the
committee room
representative hill i am here also in
the
mckinney i'm here
and i'm home in my office alone
hi i'm here in my office alone in nashua
representative osborne absent
representative richards
looks like absent as well representative
brouillard
i'm here in the lobby the clerk is here
in the lob
representative simon
absent representative smith
i'm here in my home office in manchester
by myself
good morning i am present i am at work
in an
office by myself and
absent
i think we're all set um with that
i'm going to tell you briefly the uh the
process that we're going to
um operate under here we have
two senate bills uh omnibus bills today
to hear
senate bill 100 and senate bill 142
fn um my plan for today
is to introduce
um each part
individually and let the
sponsoring senator speak to their bill
and run through all parts of senate bill
100.
um that's a little glitch to that we're
going to actually start with part four
and then we're going to start with part
one and the reason for that is a
scheduling problem
with one of the people testifying for
part four
um at some point early on here i have to
step out for a few minutes for a
uh commitment um to my constituents back
in franklin
um but i will hand things over to uh
vice chair green for for the hearings
and things will proceed
with that um i think unless there's any
comments or concerns or questions how
we're going to do that
we'll go through we'll introduce each
have each sponsoring senator speak and
then go back
to each section and and call on everyone
as they have signed up
and by part number so right back to part
one
part two part three when we get to
the general public any
problems concerns anyone here no one
with the committee that i see
hands up um with that
um i would like to call uh senator
d'alessandro
so here's my fallback um
is on the line right yes
so could representative abrami could you
introduce
senate bill 100 part four
no i can't promote him to a panelist
i'm sorry who who are you trying to rep
yes i can i can bring him over thank you
sure and i just got the word that
senator d'alessandro was on
on the way okay um he may speak second i
guess
all right as soon as i see him i'll
bring him over
representative abrami thank you mr chair
i appreciate you allowing me to go
uh first we'll be executing some bills
at
uh 9 30 over in ways and mains can you
speak up senator
representative it's very hard i'm sorry
i will speak louder um thank you i
appreciate you letting me go first here
uh it turns out i am also a co-sponsor
of
of the of the senate bill uh
so this bill uh
uh it's basically a joint committee with
the senate
to look at the charitable gaming
the regulations the oversights how
charities are selected to
be involved in all of that i was on a i
was on a commission
about six seven years ago which we we
did something similar
and we felt it was time to do it again
so uh just so you understand that there
was two
two bills there was one in the house and
one in the senate
the house bill was identical to the
senate bill with
except for reception of one one
component which i'll talk about in a
second
the house bill passed out of ways and
means unanimous you
bipartisan unanimous was on consent
calendar
the senate voted yes on that and but
then put it on the table
uh now we have this this uh section four
of senate bill 100 and what i did was i
reached out to senator d'alessandro
uh to say that can we talk about
the difference in the makeup of the
committee that's all we're going to be
talking about here is the makeup that
i said the senate can have whatever they
want they want one member from
from the ways and means and one member
from the
finance committee i brought this issue
back to ways and means
and ways and means unanimously said we
want to increase our number to four
and have two members all of the members
from ways and means two from the
majority party and two from the minority
party
which i have discussed that with senator
d'alessandro
he's fine with that so uh
i've forwarded uh some amendment
language to the chair
uh so we'd like to amend this bill this
will probably be the surviving bill
uh if you if you so choose as uh your
committee to
to pass this uh with with the amendment
uh so uh in short that's
what this is about again this the
amendment that we're talking about
i'm not only representing myself today
i'm representing
all of ways and means uh because we did
talk about it last week and voted on it
uh that we would support this uh
uh senate bill 100 part four
as amended uh
pat this is senator dallas
i'm sorry i was i had difficulty linking
up
okay thank you very very much and uh i i
will support everything that
representative obama said
i think it's about time we look at
charitable gaming there's been a
proliferation of the quote-unquote
casino
type activities that have taken place
throughout the state
it's become a multi-billion dollar
business as
as all of us know and uh when senator
o'dell
chaired a committee a number of years
ago uh the the 35
going to the charities uh was put in
place and
there have been times when that hasn't
been arrived at and the charities uh
come to us uh repeatedly and ask that
amenities be added
to charitable gaming in order to
increase their portion
of the of the renumeration
but i think we need a thorough
examination of charitable gaming
as as i said it has proliferated
throughout the state
and i think it correctly uh
representative probably but i think we
have 16 casinos
currently in operation don't we that's
the correct number yeah 16.
right so i would hope that the committee
would would support
uh part four uh with the uh brownie uh
amendment which i think is a good one
that uh i thank you very much for
touching base with me
uh with regard to it and i think we'll
have a of a good committee and do a
thorough investigation
of of this activity that that has become
a
um it's really become a big part of new
hampshire and certainly the
the charities uh cry out for uh
the revenues that they need to continue
to exist so with that mr chairman i
thank you very much for allowing me
uh to speak on behalf of part four and i
would entertain any queries that
any member of the community committee
might have thank you
thank you senator um are there any
questions from anyone in the committee
room
or senator or for representative abrami
anyone on zoom i don't see any hands
raised
i think you're good to go senator thank
you very much
i have one question uh for
representative abrami that
um the amendment only deals with the
membership of the commission correct yes
that's all
right okay thank you very much okay
thank you guys
thank you pat thank you everybody have a
great have a great great american day
patrick
okay thank you um
so that will close part four
of senate bill 100. um from that point
what i'd like to do
is uh now that we've we've uh relieved
our obligation
for um for a scheduling conflict um i'd
like to start
with uh with part one of senate bill 100
um call the sponsor uh which is senator
gray senator gray are you available
yes i am i for the record i am james
gray
uh senator for district six uh here in
new hampshire
and i'm at my uh home in rochester and
i'm alone in the room
uh part one um
deals with a very important thing and
that's
the safety of our health care workers
and other people in the hospitals
a few years ago we did look at the state
hospital
and some incidents that were happening
there
we had some success that was when the
the current commissioner of uh health
and human services
uh ms shebonet was just taking over at
the state hospital
and we had some successes and we're
trying to now
look at some of the other hospitals
and right now because of covid
and the isolation and other things um
there are those that believe that the
incidences
of violence and workplace safety
need to be looked at now
and uh we actually introduced this bill
last year
uh at the request of the hospitals and
uh
as many of them did to die to covet
death
and we believe it's
a commission that needs to happen and we
thank you senator gray are there any
questions for the senator
i have a question a question from
representative
william is this microphone on press the
red button
i did press the red button i can i can
hear you
huh you can hear me okay thank you for
coming today
um the question i have about the
hospitals and workplace safety
uh i know all the hospitals have
protocols for workplace safety
are they looking for root causes
of incidents or are they just trying to
overhaul
their policies and protocols with regard
to workplace safety
it's pretty much up to the commission
where this thing
ultimately goes uh but
right now there are are those that don't
believe that the
the uh rules that we have in place right
now are adequate
um there was a uh a a
zoom session that was held by uh senator
sherman
um and some of the doctors testified
um and their solution
more involved in patients
for patients that present themselves at
a hospital
and i particularly don't believe that
that is the solution
so we need to get the best minds in new
hampshire together
on this issue and chart a path forward
make sure that all those healthcare
workers are taught about de-escalation
techniques which is one of the things
that we used
at the state hospital which appeared to
work very well there
so again a representative
exactly where this commission is going
to go uh i can't tell you right now
but uh there are people on there that
will be smarter than i about this
seeing any okay
thank you for your testimony sir uh next
we have
uh senator haybard to speak first this
morning
uh for part three among others yes
okay well i'm i'm here uh just on behalf
of senator ward
who is the prime sponsor of this and she
couldn't make it so i'm basically just
going to introduce it as uh
part three and it's a commission uh to
differentiate the cost of education
and the cost of care for children in a
residential facility
and again it's sponsored by by senator
ward and uh
that's about as much as i can offer at
well i guess i do have a question okay
thank you for coming
um and i know you don't have a whole lot
of information but
um my question on this is
we already know what the cost of
residential care is
and it it seemed to me that it would not
be too difficult although i may totally
be wrong
to figure out what the cost of education
over and above the cost of
um providing a safe place
um with the residential setting
so i when i read this i thought geez it
would seem like it's pretty easy
tell me where i'm wrong on that i i
can't tell you either way
uh because i'm really not super familiar
with this part of it i'm just
here just to present on on behalf of
senator ward who couldn't make it
at this time uh it's basically a
commission to
check out the different uh the
differential cost of education
for the care of children residential
facilities that's that's about as far as
i can
go with this update thank you i
appreciate the questions and uh and i
think they're good
it's a good question thank you yeah
mr chairman i believe that grant bossie
is also here to
to speak to on behalf of the ward if you
would please elevate him the panelists
yes do you see him yet he's on his way
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee thank you for having me
my name is grant bosse i'm the majority
policy director for the new hampshire
senate senator ward asked me to be
around
mostly to write down any questions you
have so that she could answer them for
you
two school districts approach her uh
before the bill filing
period and talked to her about disabled
children with residential placements now
as you know
there are several ways we differentiate
state adequate education aid based on
the different needs of children
including special ed but residential
care is not part of that differentiation
formula so the
this bill this commission uh wouldn't
necessarily study what those costs are
but how those costs should if at all
be included in the adequacy formula
whether this is a
different category of differentiated aid
as opposed to some
other program that we might do outside
of the adequate education formula
uh one district had a child with a
hundred fifty thousand dollars
uh in residential expenses another
thirty thousand dollars
uh and especially for smaller school
districts this can mean
a huge hit to the budget and a huge
impact on local property taxpayers
if you get one or two kids with really
skyrocketing expenses
uh spread over a very small local
district
so uh senator ward thought that
deciding whether this might be
appropriate for differentiated aid under
the formula
was something that would require a
little bit more in-depth
study and thought that a study committee
would be the proper vehicle to do so
and she appreciates uh your
consideration
thank you for your testimony any
questions i do have a question
i seem to be the question gail today
that's right um
thank you for that explanation you know
when i was thinking residential setting
i'm
thinking more of facility rather than a
home residential setting so
thank you for that um it seems to me and
i'm not an
education guru and and
and defer to those that are um but it
seems to me that
children that require special education
have been provided with some
additional adequacy for that specific
category
and how does that
adequacy differ when someone goes into a
residential setting because
i would think the residential setting
would provide
uh care other than education per se
and then education as um
directed by the local community that is
charged with
that child's care so how
how again are we trying to figure out
what that is if we already have a
formula and i assume we do
in place for folks that that need it for
a specific education
uh thank you representative well the
current formula doesn't differentiate
between the level of care that these
uh special needs students get uh it's an
extra bump
in your district's formula but that's
whether that that
doesn't take into account um the
residential placement
services that they can really run up the
tab
so you get the same amount as a student
that is simply receiving
uh extra attention from uh somebody in
the classroom from somebody like my aunt
who was
for many years special education
provider in local public schools
um so this would this would look at
which of these costs uh much of much of
them are outside the classroom
are appropriate for state education aid
and which uh maybe should be picked up
through some other
hhs some other agency it would really
look into
not only the total money spent where
that money should be coming from
between the state between which agencies
in the state or
whether it should come from local
taxpayers thank you
thank you any further questions seeing
none
thank you and next week i'll try to
bring up uh
hello i can you hear me yes i can
so i'm speaking on part two
is this is this time you want you're
you're aren't you talking about part
three
well what i'm doing now is i'm
i'm kind of moving down the list
of the order just from top to bottom
that's all right okay
okay if you're ready for part two of
that i'm i'm fine i just wanted to say
you might we might be hopping around a
little bit but let's
let's proceed in that way thank you mr
chair this is
yes it might it might be helpful if i
actually introduce part two
before you take ms bearden oh if you
would sir yes please proceed
um i'm sorry for the confusion but i
thought we were going to
go to all the witnesses for each part
before we introduce the second one
uh again for the record i am james gray
senator from district six
and here to introduce the section of the
bill
which deals with payments in lieu of
taxes
by charitable organization this part of
the bill was requested by the assessing
standards board
which has many functions uh as we deal
with the taxes
right now one of the things that the
the assessors have found is
that there needs to be a a good look at
these payments and move taxes
and that is why they've asked for this
commission
uh to do that what portion
should be taxable uh what portion should
not be taxable
uh all issues that
because of the lack of money
in various municipalities and uh
so again they think that this needs a
good scrub and they are willing
to assist is in doing that and uh you
can see the list of uh
other people that they've suggested be
on that
commission so i would request that you
would support
uh this looking
thank you sir i apologize for going a
little out of order my sheet here
does not indicate who some people have
indicated what parts of the bill they're
speaking on other ones have it so
if we skip around a little bit i
apologize now if uh one of the things
mr chair one of the things that the
other some of the other chairmen have
done
is that when you get to a part if you
ask the participants that are going to
speak on that part to raise their hands
uh it probably would make it easier on
you and the
staff that's a great idea thank you sir
uh but let's bring up kathleen reardon
then
at this time thank you
thank you for the opportunity to speak
my name is kathleen reardon
i am the ceo of the new hampshire center
for nonprofits
which is a non-profit organization that
is dedicated to strengthening
and giving voice to our state's
nonprofit sector we have
more than 700 members that represent the
diversity of the nonprofit sector
representing all mission types as well
as sizes of organizations
in the state we are
neutral on this bill we have some
concerns
and don't see a specific urgent need to
move forward with the commission
but if the legislators decide to move
forward with one we're happy to
have a representative on the commission
just as way of background as you know
new hampshire
law provides for an exemption to
religious educational and charitable
institutions
from taxation of real estate and
personal property that are used for
mission-related purposes
and this exemption is very important to
nonprofits our financial sustainability
relies on
on this exemption in many cases and
you certainly have seen over the last
year the critical role that nonprofits
play
in aiding the health and well-being of
our communities
um from non-profit child care
organizations um
make it it possible for parents to get
back to work
um that's been really critical health
care centers
educational institutions all a wide
range of
organizations that are really part of
the common good
of our communities and essential so we
need to do what we can um to make sure
that these organizations are sustainable
in some cases non-profit organizations
voluntarily enter
into agreements with municipalities as a
good faith
effort to address
some of the municipal related expenses
however even when they do so it's really
important to note
that this diverts their funding from
their charitable mission
and many organizations have extremely um
tight buzz budgets and often their
primary source of funding is donations
um
so large pilot pilots would divert from
the charitable mission
so we do urge policymakers to avoid an
opening of the floodgate
we must be careful to not inadvertently
create policies that encourage
municipalities
to collect revenue from non-profits
that are clearly exempt by law
medium-sized smaller
organizations would not be able to
survive such a burden
so that's very important um we
understand that the assessing standards
board has an interest in convening this
commission
again as the state's primary voice of
nonprofits we don't see an urgent need
for this
but we will participate in the
commission if the legislature decides to
move forward with it
thank you i'm happy to take any
questions
yeah i have a question representative
smith
proceed uh thank you for um the
information you presented that's some
good background um
this this section is dealing with
payments in lieu of taxes
uh do you have an example of what one of
i mean like a specific organization that
pays them is that what you mean no like
what what form these payments in lieu of
taxes might be i mean are we talking
about like
donating a truck to the city i mean
they're usually a cash payment in lieu
of taxes
um and they
it is a it is a voluntary agreement that
the nonprofit
organization enters into within
municipality
okay so it's still monetary correct
uh all set no follow-up
representative we're good all good thank
you mr chairman
can you hear me can you hear me
i wonder if this person yes okay thank
you um i know that
with the current system we do allow in
some instances
payments and lower taxes to attract
businesses for example to new hampshire
and usually that's for a certain time
period
with these charitable organizations and
all are you expecting to have them
be permanent payments to lower taxes or
what
ms reardon are you still on the line and
can answer the question
um i'm not looking for pilots to be
permanent
um what the question was are are pilots
is that the question uh representative
wall won't you
i'll repeat my question i'll repeat my
question
uh right now we allow payments in lieu
of taxes
to attract businesses to new hampshire
for example
uh for these charitable organizations
are we planning to
allow permanent payments and lower taxes
or what do you know
i i don't know but i don't think that
the the tax incentives to recruit
businesses are the same
as pilots pilots again
are non-profits are exempt from paying
property taxes
for for the property that is for
charitable uses
they may enter into an agreement with
municipalities
to offset some of the municipal
costs for things like fire or you know
the regular
so you know they're not a permanent
thing it's something that the
okay thank you thank you i have a
question
is weird yes yes representative
i don't have to push my blue button
again i hope i'm all set
can you hear me here yes thank you uh i
i really don't know a whole lot about
the pilot program so my question is does
each municipality
or each town have the ability
to set um payments in lieu of taxes or
have agreements with the different
charitable organizations or are they
governed by something
issued by the state with regard to
percentages
the the um state law allows for
um pilots to take place um
and again they are voluntary um so they
are negotiations that happen at the
at the local level okay and and
is it your understanding that this
commission
would like to look at this to see
whether or not that should be changed
um my unders my understanding is that
the commission as
senator gray outlined wants to look at
what is happening with the pilots as i
mentioned you know
we want to be sure that any conversation
about pilots
recognizes the important role that
nonprofits play in our communities and
doesn't open the floodgates
for undue taxation
when they're clearly exempt from taxes
thank you i see
that senator gray has his hand raised
i'm assuming he would like to jump in to
clarify some of the questions we've had
senator gray if i could mr chairman
uh again um the
an organization say a hospital
does take services from the community
water police fire
but it may be better to look like a at a
college campus say in durham
where a great deal of
the services of that small town
may be dedicated to that tax-exempt
organization
university and this is a way to
recognize that in some cases these
non-profit organizations
can be a burden and that's the reason
for the pilot the reason to look at
these
is that when you get down to the details
there can be
profit centers or private
businesses inside of these organizations
that would not be um exempt from taxes
if there is a um
you know a lease to a particular piece
of land over in durham
you know for uh some commercial
operation
that part of that should be taxable
in some people's opinion uh
others so again what we're trying to do
is look at the whole issue trying to
to seek out fairness between the
organizations we are not trying to take
away
the tax exemption for any non-profit
organization that's working within the
law
absolutely not but we are trying to look
at those
things that are on the fringe to see if
they are
being treated adequately and that
pilot or the income that they're getting
or whatever
is being done properly so again
i i don't see you know any hospital
any service organization
being affected by this other than
if they say own a building and they're
renting that building for a commercial
operation to happen
and then that commercial according to
state law right now should be taxed
uh if a a community has in their town
hall
uh a building or a portion of the
building that they rent to somebody
it is that should also not be taxed
i should be taxed so if there's any
additional questions
on that i'd be happy to try to field
them no thank you that
helped a lot thank you any additional
questions
see no hands raised no none inside here
are there any other people willing
wishing to testify
now would be a good time to raise your
hand
there are a couple of hands up on mr
chairman
um the chair would call paula minihan
who is from the new hampshire hospital
association
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee
for the record paula minihan senior vice
president state government relations
with the new hampshire hospital
association
i actually wanted to testify on both
part one and part two if i
if you would um allow me to i did not
i was not following the order of um of
testimony
i apologize for that um i think that
actually is our um our problem well what
i would like you to do is
is continue on uh testifying with part
two
and then we will circle back and uh and
start with part one
okay certainly um so i do wanna
testify on part two as well um we are
not um the hospital association is not
supportive of the commission to study
payment in lieu of taxes or
pilots as they have been referenced um
this bill was introduced last year but
did not pass out of the senate election
law
and municipal affairs committee i did
submit um written testimony
for both parts one in part two so i will
um
not get into a lot of details as ms rear
and um i
completely agree with what her testimony
indicated
we have concerns about um this
commission
not exactly clear what will be
what will result from it um but i can
explain
hospitals are big um obviously big
charitable
institutions um we um
the hospitals make it a priority to
engage and collaborate with the
community partners to share resources
skills expertise leverage opportunities
to meet the most critical needs of their
communities and make the vision of a
healthy place a reality
we do have significant concerns about
this part too which would establish a
commission
that in lieu of payment in lieu of taxes
hospitals do pay
23 of new hampshire's 26 community
hospitals are non-profit
three of them are for-profit under the
hca umbrella
um and they are as ms reardon indicated
exempted from property taxes
under rsa 72 some of them however
have negotiated and made arrangements to
make payments in lieu of taxes
otherwise known as pilots those are
decisions made at a local level and we
believe that's where these decisions
should remain they are exempt from
hospitals are exempt from paying
property taxes in return for their
charitable benefits
they provide to the community so it's
not like they don't pay taxes and don't
provide anything um new hampshire's
hospitals
just um in 2018 had um
contributed over 500 million dollars in
community benefits um i have a report
that i'm happy to share with the
committee
that outlines what all went into that
but
a big portion of that is financial
assistance for those that
um cannot otherwise afford to pay for
their health care
um including the value of unreimbursed
medicaid
to not to name a couple hospitals do
work collaboratively and to identify and
uh assess the needs of their communities
through
detailed community needs assessments um
that happen
um every three years i believe
and those are provide those reports are
through the chair the office of
charitable trust in the attorney
general's office
um so decisions again about whether a
community and a non-profit hospital or
other entity should enter into a pilot
is a local decision we have them
throughout the state
we have one up in hanover we have them
in new london they're all over the state
but again that is negotiated and just to
be clear
if a hospital is um if there is a
for-profit
portion of the hospital um
an independent prac not an independent
but a hospital
if they're own a physician office
building for instance they pay taxes on
that um
if they rent it from the town um or the
city
there are a lot of them in concord for
instance that concord hospital rents
out a number of office buildings from
the
city um or from the landlord that's a
little different they don't pay taxes on
that for instance so it varies
throughout the state every single town
every single
relationship with the hospital in the
city is is different
we are concerned that this study
commission could create the expectation
as again ms reading indicated that
nonprofits
exempt from property taxes be required
to enter into a pilot
that does take away from that their
charitable mission
and as i said hospitals contribute
currently 500 million dollars in chair
in
in community benefits and that would be
impacted
and that is a very big concern to us
because vulnerable
populations benefit from those community
benefits we don't
believe that this type of mandate from
the legislature is the right approach
and we believe the best approach would
be to lead these decisions to the local
decision makers to determine how best to
serve their communities
and that is my testimony on part two and
i will um
um i will shut down my video and then
when you're ready for part one i will um
come back when you're ready for me
but i'm happy to answer any questions
chairman
thank you i will ask if there's any
questions in
the committee room any questions
on zoom seeing none
hold tight we will be back to you will
do thank you
uh there are other people really
yes michael lachance says there we go
okay
mr lachance welcome to the legislative
administration
you're speaking on part two of senate
mr chance you're muted there you go
i apologize mr chairman uh good morning
uh mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is michael chance i'm
the ceo for the ymca of greater nashua
i'm here today on behalf of the ymca
alliance of new hampshire which is
comprised of nine ymcas in our state
uh the ymca alliance opposes part two of
senate bill 100 to establish a
commission to study the pilots
the alliance feels this commission is
unnecessary and potentially harmful to
community-based non-profits like the y
that provide essential services to new
hampshire families
the first ymca in new hampshire we were
founded in 1852
today these nine wise serve more than
100 000 granite staters each year
through our programming and services the
new hampshire wives provide essential
services in our communities to some of
the state's most vulnerable residents
at the why these services include child
care hunger relief
community-based chronic disease
prevention programs
and by providing these ymcas i'm sorry
by providing these services
ymcas are actually lessening the burden
on government
our tax exempt status is a critical
component for us to be able to provide
these services
to people in need the new hampshire wise
we work hard to eliminate barriers so
that everybody can thrive the y in fact
a core portion of our mission is not
turning people away because of their
inability to pay
each year the new hampshire y's provide
an average of five million dollars in
financial assistance
for individuals in the state to be able
to access these services
these are scholarships for camp child
care wellness programs
uh requiring the wise to pay pilots
would have a significant and
negative impact on our ability to
provide these programs in this level of
support
uh it would also disappropriately affect
those that are most
vulnerable in our community the
low-income families individuals with
mental health and substance abuse
challenges
seniors and immigrants we respectfully
urge the committee to remove part two of
senate bill 100
mandated pilots would directly results
in the wide and other community-based
organizations
being forced to serve fewer of new
hampshire's residents
than those most vulnerable we remain
committed to working in partnership with
our state and local governments and
other not-for-profits
to strengthen the communities across the
state and we thank you for your service
thank you uh are there you will be
willing to take questions
uh do i see anyone on zoom no hands
raised
thank you for your testimony thank you
cam's muted
i see no other people willing to testify
or wanting to testify
on part two i will close the hearing on
part two of senate bill 100 and i will
circle back
to part one of senate bill 100
which dealt with a commission to study
i understand we've had the prime sponsor
senator
gray and do we have
anyone else i know
ms minahan okay
she's waited long enough let's bring her
up
thank you again um chairman and members
of the committee
um again for the record paula minihan
with the hospital association
we are very supportive of part one of
senate bill 100
um and we do thank senator gray for
introducing um this bill
for us a couple years ago um delay
it was reintroduced last year because it
never crossed over
due to the pandemic from the senate
however it did pass the senate with
strong support
we along with other health care provider
organizations
asked that the commission be established
to address the ongoing concerns
our health care workers face every day
while caring for patients
the sin the incidence of of violence in
health care
against health care workers in new
hampshire and other health care settings
continues unfortunately
hospitals and other providers have
implemented various policies and
strategies to address
these growing concerns however we
believe a more comprehensive
multi-disciplinary approach is warranted
it should not be the expectation of a
nurse an aide
a physician or another caregiver to be
verbally or physically harmed while
doing their job
caring for others we do look forward to
working with the members of the
commission
and as senator gray indicated it is um
and i mentioned um if you look at
um the members of the commission it is
definitely multi-disciplinary and that's
what we believe
is necessary to really dig into
all the issues and to address um i'm
sorry i'm not sure which representative
asked the earlier question but on page
two
starting on line 24 the
um charge of the commission is very
comprehensive
and it really would look at everything
and anything
necessary to address the concerns
that have been raised and to try to
determine again as a comprehensive
approach what we could what we could do
if it needs to be a statutory change or
what other um
tools there are to address this we do um
support the creation of the study
commission to focus on the healthcare
worker safety
so we can begin to work on with all
stakeholders and the legislature
in this very important issue and i just
will point out that
unfortunately with the pandemic it's
actually gotten worse
um we um and senator gray did try to get
this passed last year
because he understands this has been an
issue for a while
and it's gotten it has gotten worse and
um so we are
a little desperate um to get this
commission going so we
we do um strongly support it and
encourage
um you to pass part one i am happy to
answer any questions
thank you thank you are there any
there are questions um senator uh
representative ruler
thank you mr chair and thank you for
coming and testifying on this subject
my question is has the new hampshire
hospital association as a whole
done any preliminary studies hearings
investigations
for its hospitals concerning workplace
safety
and as a second part of that question
and if they have what has come out
of that study that collaboration among
the different hospitals across the state
um thank you for that question
representative
um so a couple things the security
officers collect
information on a monthly basis um
regarding some of the incidents um that
is kind of
that's confidential but the um idea was
to
aggregate that information um for the
commission
um so we um are collecting that
information from them
um and then our um our commission on uh
quality commission and patient safety
commission which
um has met for over 20 years it is a
permanent commission
on the legislature made that a permanent
commission a couple years ago um
by a bill sponsored by senator rosenwald
they have also been working on this
issue um
again that is um protected information
um that is the way that the commission
has been established
um so they various hospitals that
includes every single hospital in the
state and every single um ambulatory
surgery center in the state
they cl they have been working on this
issue as well
um in various um components and
and then um i think representative
excuse me uh i apologize senator
gray was talking about some of the
training um the de-escalation
training um that was started actually by
the state uh by the state hospital and
it's called secure
it's an acronym um and i apologize i
i should know what it is but i don't off
the top of my head um
and that is basically de-escalation
training that we got a grant
um the foundation for healthy
communities which is an affiliate of the
hospital association was able to access
a grant
to pay for that training and
pre-pandemic
the um folks including the chief
security officer who's part of the state
police
from the state hospital was going around
training
hospital e.d staffs and others
throughout the state and a number of
hospitals took advantage of that
training
unfortunately that got shut down when
the pandemic hit last
march and has not started up again due
to
our limitations with visitors etc um so
i would say that we've done a lot
um the problem is we can't
go further without getting others
involved
including the court system including the
state
there are limitations relative to
what can be done based on state law um
so that's what we that's why we need the
commission um and as senator gray
said he brought a number of stakeholders
together oh gosh
senator gray i'm trying to remember when
that was but probably 2018
when a constituent of his raised this
issue and we've been working
on this ever since so um again yes the
hospitals do a lot
it's just it's not a multi-disciplinary
approach and that's what this commission
would be charged with
follow up thank you for that i i
understand that
that security officers have been
collecting data
i also understand that the quality
commission
working on it has protective information
and i also understand that training has
occurred through the secure act
my question really was has the
new hampshire hospital association
created a group of folks to look at all
this
understanding that we do have some
information that's protected
that could be set aside in just the
incident or whatever it was brought
forward
has the new hampshire hospital
association sat and met
to deal with the issues the quality
issues and the training issue and talked
about the best practice for them going
forward
rather than bringing it forward to the
legislature in a condition where there's
already a commission that perhaps
um so i would say that yes they have
again done this primarily through the
quality commission
the issue is this is happening in
nursing homes
this is happening in um in the home for
home care
workers um and nurses unfortunately when
they the
so we need um so we need the
the nurses association we need the
hospice and home care association
the long-term care association the
healthcare association the hospital
association
um along with the um others that are
listed
on um the medical society we we need all
everyone to be at the table including
the um
the um the employees
the state employees association etc to
the attorney general's office because
again there are laws that are
limiting um whether what can more can be
done
um so yes we have done a lot
um we have done a lot the problem is we
um we need to do more
um and and the security officers work
day and night
on their they work 24 7 to protect
obviously the staff
the patients and others that that enter
the hospital
but um there are um there are
issues there are underlying issues
including state laws
that um limit what more a health care
provider can do
uh thank you one more follow-up is there
a chance that you can
because you're very familiar with this
is there a chance that you can send this
committee
a list of the state laws that limit
further
information or work that you're able to
do
um i will do the best i can
yes i will i don't know if anyone from
the attorney general's office is is
planning to testify but they um they are
um also um expert obviously more expert
than me
in this area but yes i will um do the
best i can
i appreciate that thank you sure sure
seeing none thank you very much
are you speaking on part one it's not
clear on
she muted you are muted miss witner
sorry i had to reboot yes um i'm here to
speak on part one
okay um speak away welcome to the
legislative administration
thank you very much i greatly appreciate
the opportunity to speak to this
committee on support for
senate bill 100 part one i'm a resident
of the town of amherst
new hampshire and i'm also the coach
government affairs co-chair for the
emergency
nurses association new hampshire state
council
i as an emergency room nurse i have
personally experienced
patients or witnessed patients acting
aggressively and combatively
and i have been fortunate however to
never have experienced
any physical assault however a 2009
study conducted by the emergency nurses
association
found that 25 of the respondents
to this survey had experienced physical
assault
more than 20 times in the past three
years
another uh 20 of the respondents had
experienced
verbal abuse more than 200 times in the
past three years
even more concerning however was the
fact that
the majority of the nurses in this
survey did not report
these incidences the the reasons are
multi-factorial
uh such as they don't they understand
the patient was
not in their right mind that they were
perhaps
experiencing delirium or dementia and
they didn't want the patient to get in
trouble but nonetheless
this is a pervasive problem within all
health care settings and i would echo
what paula minihan mentioned that it's
not strictly limited to
emergency departments and hospitals but
it's pervasive or happens
in all healthcare settings ambulatory
care settings
long-term care settings home care
settings so urgent
care so it really needs to be a
comprehensive
commission to examine this problem
extensively
further i'd add that the american nurses
association conducted a survey in 2019
and the results of this survey of
tens of thousands of nurses across the
country found that one in four nurses
had experienced
a physical or verbal assault yet again
here
20 to 60 of these assaults went
unreported
by the nurse um
we conducted i worked with paula minahan
back in 2018 i participated in the
meeting that senator gray called
of multiple stakeholders at that time i
was the executive director of the new
hampshire nurses association
which i'm not currently in that capacity
and um
at that time we orchestrated a study
done for merrimack county here in new
hampshire
and that study um found that 24
of the nurses reported experiencing
physical acts of aggression
and 35 percent experienced some level of
verbal aggression
and again almost 20 percent reported
that they didn't report
these incidences so we i really want to
encourage
oh um one other thing um there i've i've
reached out to
um a nursing emergency nurse colleague
and i'm hopeful that she's here to
testify today or will submit written
testimony
but this nursing colleague was assaulted
in the emergency department while on
duty back last fall
and was strangled to unconsciousness by
a psychiatrically boarding patient
in fact um when i was in graduate school
i
wrote a paper uh because a patient a
nurse
the patient attacked a nurse at elliot
hospital back in 2015
and that patient was killed as a result
of this attack
so my the paper i wrote was on the issue
of psychiatric boarding in the emergency
department and that
you know we need to do something about
that and fortunately the state did look
into
that and i was pleased that that that
had become less of a problem of course
until a pandemic came out and the
problem
has been exacerbated so anyway um
thank you for your time and i'm more
than happy to take questions on this
subject
thank you for your testimony uh we do
have one question representative ruler
i think i am the question gail today uh
i'm awful sorry but if you said your
name i didn't get that
my name is joan widmer um my clinical
background is that
as an emergency nurse but i have also
served in
um advocacy capacities for the new
hampshire nurses association
and the emergency nurses association yes
other than just getting your name i do
given the fact that the folks that come
into the emergency room
may have psychiatric issues whether it
be the elderly with dementia
or the violent or mentally ill folks
that come in and actually are the ones
that that do the assault
um it seems to me that
the verbal abuse and some of the
physical assault
is is combined as a problem and so
i wonder if we have seen in the state of
new hampshire
um more reporting since we've become
aware of this
by way of hospital policy and procedures
with not only the nurses association in
the state but if you're in any kind of a
national organization if that has become
uh something that we need to put forward
and have we done that already
in the way of policies certainly um i
know that for instance the american
nurses association
is actively advocating that nurses
report all incidences
um and i know that um there are uh
superstructures in place
within most um hospital organizations to
um encourage reporting however i
remember in a conversation with paula
minnigan several years ago
and she mentioned that um you know the
the
number of reported incidences by
hospitals varies dramatically
if a memory serves me from zero to 400
incidences in
in the past year so clearly
there's a discrepancy regardless of
hospital institutional size
that that is an issue of whether things
are reported or not and i think
to some extent it depends on the nurses
management and
or the the executive management within
the the organization
but again that is limited to hospital
settings and this
situation is not at all limited to
hospital situations
however i do agree that i think nurses
are
being sensitized to the importance of
reporting it no nurse wants to see a
patient
who is not in their right faculties so
to speak to
be punished inappropriately however
short of reporting it there are other
things that we can do
as an organization or as a state through
this commission other things that can be
done
such as de-escalation techniques often
they're limited to emergency department
nurses
however we have patients experiencing
delirium
and in the icu we have patients
experiencing dementia in long-term care
so it it really can't be constrained to
just emergency nursing staff
so i hope that answers your question
it it does but i'd like to follow up
with one that came out of your response
the de-escalation techniques has that
become
a state policy with the nurses
association in new hampshire
for training for not only just emergency
rooms
but for nursing on all levels or
practitioners on all levels i'm not
aware of any state
policy one way or the other i believe
that most
hospitals and most healthcare
organizations
have some level of policy that within
their institution but it goes very
dramatically
i know for instance when i first became
an emergency room nurse
i was trained in um what's called moab
management of aggressive behavior and in
de-escalation techniques but that
training was not provided to me when i
worked on
another inpatient unit so again even
within an institution the level of
training
um is is varied and there are again
other techniques besides that
so for instance maybe there's uh
conveniently placed emergency
notification bells
or devices worn on the person i know
some hospitals in different states have
emergency call buttons that all staff
wear at all times
so again there's a lot of different
things we can do but in order to know
what's right for us here in new
hampshire
the purpose of this commission is to get
all of the stakeholders together to talk
about the issue and
then to propose solutions that will help
to truly address the problem and it's
not always a law enforcement issue but
it might be other things as well thank
you
any other questions from the committee
or on zoom seeing none i would like to
follow up with one
um uh paula manahan mentioned
uh that laws are limiting what can be
done
um are you also uh testifying to
that and and would you be aware of any
of these laws that
are limiting what can be done
unfortunately that's not my
my area of expertise so i can't offer
anything there i apologize no
that's fine that's perfectly valid
answer thank you very much for
testifying
appreciate it thank you i appreciate the
time today and i i strongly encourage
everyone to to vote out to pass on this
particular part of the bill it's
it's long overdue and very very needed
seeing none
this would be the time that anyone any
member of the public that would like to
raise their hand and
seeing none we're going to close part 1
senate bill 100 move to
[Music]
part 3 of senate bill 100 which is
establishing a commission to
differentiate the cost of education and
the cost of care for children in a
residential facility
this is exactly the experience that they
had in the senate
when this bill was heard
no one testified no one introduced it
actually
actually mr chairman i think we did talk
about part three earlier
right um it was introduced here
uh by senator avard but um
but that was at my behest because we
didn't have anyone
sign up to to introduce it
right grant bossie appeared for senator
ward
oh okay great uh
and mr boss he spoke on part three
yes he did okay great um i'm catching up
here too as well
uh it's complicated it is it is
so having no one else willing to
or wanting to testify on part three
i'm ready to close the hearing on part
three and
we've already done part four so we would
jump
is there anyone signed up or anyone
wanting to speak
to part four establishing a
we will close the hearing on part 4 of
senate bill 100 and move
to part 5. of
senate bill 100 establishing a committee
to study the effects of covet 19
lockdowns quarantines and school and
all right it's been introduced yet yeah
that was not introduced no senator avar
didn't introduce me
he did it i've got a text message from
senator avard saying he had to leave
i thought he was going to testify he was
okay all right um
is there any other sponsors of
pull up
okay
senator uh representative ruler would
you mind introducing
uh part five of uh
senate bill 100 so that we can entertain
testimony sure my name is claire roulard
i am a member of the legi admin i'm
introducing
part five of senate bill 100
which is establishing a committee to
study the effects of covert 19 lockdowns
quarantines and school and business
closings
thank you um and hearing that there are
okay yep let's bring up representative
harrigan
welcome to legislative administration
well thank you very much mr chair i'm
rev
timothy horrigan from trafford county
district six the towns of durham
and madbury or as i like to call it a
greater bad berry
i'm i'm i think this part five is
valuable i think you might uh
might want to reword the section a
little bit because
now of course it just says the effects
of cohort 19 like down
quarantine school business closings um
but
of course you can study i guess the
beneficial effects because uh
i think uh you know the the kuvin 19 um
pandemic the virus is one of you know
it's extraordinarily dangerous
it's killed more people in the united
states i think anything since the
civil war took millions nationwide and
um
certainly the the uh various things that
we tried
uh to slow down the spread of the
pandemic um they were
but they did have some side effects i
think that this is like just this
proposal a little bit over
over overly slanted towards you know the
negative effects
of the various public health measures
that were taken so
maybe rewording it a little bit would be
nice and actually
might even be good to have some better
data about the actual effects of the
virus itself on the people of new
hampshire because i think there's
a little bit lack of clarity on that um
and we certainly
we probably all got a large number of
emails about another bill that's
in edna and there are people actually
saying with a straight face for example
that uh the vaccine makes you more
dangerous to people around you which
pretty much flies in the face of like
200 years of science and so i think
i think perhaps broadening the scope of
it a little bit to a get some more hard
data about
what actually did happen to us during
the pandemic and you know
b maybe talk about how these measures
actually work it's not just about parts
that didn't work and there's also of
course
the issue of uh how well we distribute
the vaccines and then the
treatments not that we have very many
effective treatments but um
so i think that's uh so i'm um
not actually against having this uh
committee but i think it needs to uh
i think we need to support a very
different and broader scope for it than
just the narrow issues that uh
came over in the senate so that's uh
that's just
i'd like to say uh gonna say briefly not
as briefly as i thought it was going to
so that thank you thank you for your
testimony will you be willing to
take questions sure why not
no well we don't have any um
thank you very much for your testimony
and
moving on to ah
um mr bossie you would like to testify
on uh on part five of
uh mr chairman thank you and uh thank
you for having me back uh senator avard
did have to leave for other hearings
it's a very busy day
here at the state house he wanted me to
talk to you about
uh the reasons he introduced this
commission a
constituent actually came to him with a
request that there are unintended
consequences to the unprecedented
actions we've taken over the last year
to slow the spread of the covet 19 virus
particularly among vulnerable
populations and i think we're just
starting to realize what some of those
are
the senator thought it would be a good
idea to have a
disciplined look at the effect that
the isolation that we've imposed on
ourselves has had
on vulnerable students on people with
ptsd
let's look at what this time locked in
our homes
communicating only through screens has
had
and if there are any uh follow-ups that
we can have
any policy solutions we can have
to address those consequences and
as is the case of anybody suggesting a
study committee
senator evert is willing to serve on
that study committee if
need be so i thank you for your
consideration
thank you mr bossie uh would you be
willing to take questions or
i would i would likely have to uh get
those questions to senator avar but i'll
do my best
excellent um i have one hand from
representative ruler
i guess you can guess who's going to ask
the question um
i understand that senator avad would
serve on this and
the prior testimony would like to expand
the bill to positive
issues treatments vaccines and how it's
affected positively
would you please ask senator avad if he
the purpose of the committee i will uh
forward that question on to him
thank you i see a hand
uh representative expedia thank you mr
chair and uh just you know if you could
pass this message along as well i see
that the
um you know the committee is made up of
mostly legislators and i think
you know for given given what some of
the
or some of the outcomes you want to see
and seeing you know you want if
if we were to truly have this committee
i think you would need to expand it to
definitely have
um i mean education uh for educators you
would need i mean
given that you would probably need to
expand it to also include
um people in the medical field um
i think if you want to make it as
comprehensive as possible
and truly study lockdowns i think rather
than just have legislators i
you know i think we have some great
legislators who are who are
members of um the health field but i
think we need to
we would probably have to take a bigger
look at it and it will probably have to
be amended so
um if you could pass that on to the
senator that would be great
sure uh representative i think what
you're talking about would be the
difference between a study committee
which is generally
uh made up of legislators it's it's a
group of lawmakers that create this
this ad hoc or sometimes official group
to study a particular issue and what
you're talking about would be a study
commission which would say
have the uh the commissioner of
education the commissioner of dhhs
and uh a number of stakeholder groups
that are laid out in a
larger more formal process whether you
go with a study committee or a study
commission obviously that's a decision
that you as the committee have to make
senator evart thought that this would be
appropriate as a study committee
and nothing would preclude that
committee from calling in commissioner
blue commissioner shibanet
experts on ptsd experts on
dealing with children with autism
whatever experts need to
be heard from could then be brought into
the study committee to make sure we
heard from them
um so i i don't think there's anything
inconsistent between what senator evard
is looking for and what you're talking
about
the question is just what sort of
structure are you having do you want a
study committee
or do you want a study commission all
no further questions for
mr bossie seeing none thank you very
much grant
good to see you again thank you and i'm
around for part six as well when you get
to that
uh we may be at that now
are we at that now no other hands raise
for part
five you're up grant
go uh thank you this also from senator
avard
has to do with the jetty out at uh
hampton beach
it's um you know kind of a rock pier uh
and it's point four miles extending out
into the atlantic ocean
it is a very popular hiking trail people
like to walk out onto it
and kind of get the view from the middle
of the ocean as opposed to from the
beach
however it is not particularly safe
uh people have fallen off they've been
uh search and rescue missions
um been called for and uh
it is certainly not uh handicapped
accessible
so uh people with any sort of
um whether from wheelchair or just
walking
people that have trouble walking
unassisted and need a cane
they can't go out on the jetty so
senator rayvard wanted to study the idea
of building a pier out over that jetty
so you could have
accessibility to the public in what is a
very popular
destination on hampton beach
and would ask for your consideration
thank you very much
wanting to speak to this uh
representative renzullo
you hear me know there you are all right
thank you very much mr chair uh good
morning i think it's morning
uh mandy renzullo i represent hudson and
pelham i am also
the chair of the house resources
recreation and development committee
and legislation concerning the park
system
is under the purview of
the resources committee i
do support the bill the bill
establishing a committee to study
building a pier over the jetty at
hampton beach state park
for access for people with disabilities
uh
it state parks are the crown jewels of
hudson
excuse me of the crown jewels of new
hampshire
and hampton beach is the hope diamond
of this of our state parks so
a lot more than normal will be riding on
the work of the proposed
peer committee the idea sounds a lot
uh sounds uh very interesting it's an
interesting concept
but the work of the proposed committee
is
necessary for the next step it's worth
the effort
and i hope the committee will approve
the bill uh or will prove part six of
the bill
i look forward to the testimony of
director bryce who could fill in
uh a lot of information uh on
on the on the the area and the park
system
thank you thank you representative
and i would point out you are the crown
don't tell anybody um
i don't see any questions for chairman
randullo but i would
take his advice and see if
the director of parks commission is on
bryce
do you know representative if he was
testifying today
or just signing up i i did receive
written testimony from him
okay i just i just assumed that he was
testifying if you
if not i could i do have his written
testimony here in front of me i don't
know if i
if you want me to read it or does
everyone have copies of it
could you paraphrase it i think we do
have copy i have a copy i don't know i
think everyone else does
um were there particular highlights that
you would like to mention
yeah he does support uh the study uh
committee
and the so he does support the
the bill uh he was he uh does speak to
the uh
uh collaboration that the uh governor's
commission on disability that the parks
have had
uh with issues concerning
uh the disabled
um yes he mentions the work with fish
and game
department to construct an accessible
fishing platform
the he also underlines that
it's important to note that the new
hampshire state parks
they is operationally self-funded
through the revenue collected from fees
services
rentals and retail so and so
expanding visitor access to the state
park is a worthy endeavor
and let's provided we have to continue
make certain that
we continue the parks revenue stream to
ensure the long-term viability
and financial health of the
he asked that the study committee will
while he goes on and asked that the
study committee
consider identifying the appropriate
agencies they'll be responsible for the
inspection and ongoing maintenance and
repairs
of the of the pier so uh
he said thank you for the opportunity to
submit this letter
and that's that's that's it but uh
i think uh you know he isn't he is in
favor of the
of the committee thank you
representative
thank you um would you would you be able
to explain a little bit
um i understand a project like this the
the peer over the jetty would not be
um from the general fund it would be
handled from
their own self-contained
revenue source uh no the uh uh
well first of all i don't know where the
funding would would come from that would
be i think something that the com
that the peer uh that the peer committee
would have to
uh have to have to decide on or look for
uh nor what uh we the
there are no general funds for
operational
uh activities on the park in other words
the people
paying them tickets or from or getting
in
uh is all that's the that is the source
of park funding you know
the the plates and other
other other items
the there is uh
the parks system does get funds from the
state
for capital improvements uh
that uh so so there have been uh
capital improvement funds from from the
state to find to
my knowledge but no operational funds no
there's no general funds
uh comes from that where the funding
would come from
uh is a good question i mean if i mean
the
committee uh but the committee will have
to find out
possibly you know just looking ahead
knowing that the
availability of federal funding might
have
might be available especially there
seems to be a lot of money flying around
so but again
these are all things that this uh
committee would have to look at
and i would hope they'd look at it yes
it would
anything else um did i answer your
question
you did i did um i'd like to just follow
up on that um
lately i've been hearing on the news
that um
that the governor is interested in using
some of this federal money
um for four different projects one of
which was
um state parks would would that
type would that be a trigger for
something
of a project like this is that the kind
of thing i
they did indicate that none of the rules
had been
received as yet but is that the kind of
money you're talking about
from the federal government uh
i've used obviously i don't know uh
specifically the rules i have not
uh talked to director bryce about
uh what his uh what his what
plans he has uh has made but
again if i were on the
uh if if i were on this com
this uh committee i probably would be
asking that exact same question that you
are
uh speaking of the committee um i i
believe in an earlier conversation you
had mentioned that
um you would be submitting
um amendment information to me for the
membership of this
this committee if you would like i will
i will do that or i can do uh you
or i could i can do it right now
or i could do it now or i can uh
i would prefer i would prefer something
in writing that
indicates uh your suggestion right now
it shows
uh two members of the senate appointed
by the president
and three members of the house of
representatives appointed by the speaker
um my understanding was you
thought that could be further delineated
uh yes i do uh would you
i i yes i will yes i i will submit to
that
uh in writing uh after this meeting
thank you thank you very much any
further questions for representative
for chairman renzullo
seeing none thank you very much for your
help
thank you any other members of the
public or
or members on zoom that would like to
speak about
or on senate bill 100 part
part six study
building appear over the jetty at
hampton beach
for disability access seeing none i will
close
the hearing on part six and i will close
senate bill 100 with that i'm going to
move
to since we're past the time i
allotted for yep by a half hour
senate bill 142.
this has multiple parts three i believe
so what we will do is again um
ask the prime sponsors the senators to
introduce their part and um
and then we will move circle back uh
again beginning at part one for
members of the public to testify part
one
um was senator birdsell i believe if
senator burnsell is available to
introduce part one
um is anyone available to first
for part two oh
no
up i see a hand raised that's senator
right good morning mr chairman good
morning
senator uh you're here to uh introduce
part three
um yes i am do you have anyone to
introduce parts one and two
i do not okay if you don't mind then
mr chairman i will make it easy for your
committee and i will introduce all three
parts
um please be aware that i have to be
excuse me off
by 11 because i have another hearing
that i must
that's attend season senator um i know
i'm i'm ready for you though if you
would like to go ahead and introduce
um one two and three that would be
terrific
okay thank you thank you very much mr
chairman um
for the record my name is senator uh
senator sharon
carson i have the pleasure of
representing senate district 14
which comprises the towns of londonderry
hudson and auburn
and i have for your consideration this
morning senate bill 142
fda fn which seeks to adopt omnibus
legislation relative to certain
certain study committees this bill seeks
to
in the first part reestablish the
commission to study
the incidents of post-traumatic stress
disorder
in first responders it also requires
first responders to have mental health
training
focusing on post-traumatic stress
disorder
the second part is relative to the
commission to study barriers
to increased land development in new
hampshire
and the third part and seeks to
establish the commission to study grand
families in new hampshire
mr chairman my testimony to open um
is basically what senator burnsell had
told
our committee which is the senate
executive departments and administration
committee
she said um the commission has existed
for the past six years
and there is still a lot of work to
cover
um but see it also dictates that the
commission will study
and requires mental health training for
first responders
she said that she was working on an
amendment um
to include workers compensations
definition of first responders
including firefighters first responders
emergency medical services personnel and
dispatchers
you will find mr chairman that that
language has been included
and was amended by the senate and she
also said
it requires police officers to go to the
fire academy for mental health training
focusing on
post traumatic stress disorders the
committee
also amended the um the bill with a
section to include
a representative from the department of
corrections
that was recommended by the department
um mr chairman are you going to go
section by section or would you like me
to hold on and have folks testify
on the first section actually i would
like to come
back to the first section and have folks
testify on that
um okay that's fine i'll start i will
stay on and you just let me know when
you're ready for the second part
i'm ready for the second part okay
this bill was filed by um senators
perkins quoca
she she is available to speak okay
that's terrific i'm
i'm confused however about i or
concerned about
your need to leave by 11 o'clock
um would it be possible uh senator
perkins woke up for
senator carson to speak on part three
so that she would be available to
head to her meeting would that be all
uh however you'd like to do a chair is
fine my introduction is very brief
why don't you go ahead why don't you go
ahead with your introduction to senator
to part two and then we'll allow the
remaining time to senator carson
okay sounds great um good morning
committee members for the record i'm
senator rebecca perkins coca from senate
district 21 representing the city of
portsmouth and the towns of madbury lee
durham newington
newmarket and new fields i'm the prime
sponsor of part two
of sb 142 fn reestablishing the
committee to study
barriers to increase land development in
new hampshire
the reason for re-establishing the
commission previously known as the sb-43
commission or the density commission
is that it did not get to complete its
work i hope that we can all agree the
need for housing is urgent in our state
and it's imperative that we continue
pushing to find solutions that we can
add to the toolbox
our job at the state level is to provide
support resources
ideas and tools to our municipalities so
they can meaningfully engage in planning
and policy conversations around housing
in its own future
with awareness of the overall impact to
the state in our economy
due to the pandemic this important
conversation initiated by senator fuller
clark was unable to meet sufficiently to
finish its mission
so i asked the committee to vote ought
to pass to allow the group to resume its
work and look ahead to the next wave of
housing legislation
thank you mr chair and i'm happy to
answer questions before or
after senator carson introduces part
three
thank you senator uh i will be back to
you senator carson can you go
with part three and i sure can thank you
very much mr chairman
um the third part of the bill seeks to
re-establish
the commission to study grand families
in new hampshire
um this was a piece of legislation that
was passed a few years ago
and it was noted at the time as being uh
the first in the nation piece of
legislation
during the opioid crisis to engross to
involve grandparents in the process
they have done an incredible amount of
work and have been a great resource
for the uh for the division of youth and
family services
and department of health and human
services and
all this legislation does is it allows
us to continue its work for
five more years um and i'd also like to
bring up the point that
um they have also been affected by the
opioid and ethiopia but
by coving by not being able to meet so
that
that hasn't helped either um i just
recently read an article
uh that because of covid we've
kind of put the opioid issue on the back
burner
and unfortunately they're predicting
that this issue is going to surge to the
forefront again
just because of um the isolation
and the other social um byproducts i
guess if you want to call it
of um of coven and that they're
predicting we're going to see a surge of
uh cases where people are going to need
help because
of an addiction to an opioid so
um we'd like to keep this commission in
place
allow them to continue to work providing
resources to
families and to the state and quite
frankly to the legislative legislators
by providing accurate and up-to-date
information
on what grandparents face when they're
given custody
of their children we had passed a few a
law a few years ago
that gave grandparents really the first
right to take their grandchildren rather
than putting them in foster care
um we think this is a great thing and it
has worked very very well for
us here for in new hampshire um
we all six new england states do have
commissions on grand families
and again we just like to be able to
continue this commission
to be able to study this issue and to be
able to work
with the state and with families and
local communities
on helping these families through what
it i think we can all agree is a very
difficult time
so at this point mr chairman i will
conclude my testimony
thank you thank you uh senator
uh do you have a minute or two if there
are any yes
i'll be more i i will try to um answer
some questions
if not hopefully there's going to be
some folks who will be able to answer
your questions
better than i can i have one question
from you from senator roulard
senator rouletti just elevated i'm sorry
hey
senator i like that idea she's always
been a senator to me
um i appreciate you coming today um
this is a very important um commission
and it's done some great work uh i we we
were sent information
from our um legislative
person uh pam smarling on on
the information that has been online for
grant families department of health and
human services as well as other
things online and i and i imagine that a
lot of that
came from the grand family's
uh work throughout this process
um is there anything specific
that we would like to try to accomplish
over the next five years even though we
don't know what's going to come
in the next five years but do you have
anything in in your site that you would
like to accomplish
with this commission ins specifically
thank you for the question uh
representative roulard
um there's a number of things that i'd
like to see i think
first and foremost is to strengthen
those ties
that we that this order that this
commission has with the state
you are correct they have been an
excellent resource
for uh for our state in providing
information
to make it much much easier for families
to get help on grand families i'd also
like to see stronger connections with
non-profits
i think that that is key um for the uh
just for informational purposes
i am the vice chair of the new hampshire
foster
and adoptive parents association and
we do a lot of work with grand families
where uh for whatever reason children
have been
taken away from their parents and
they're given to get to grandparents who
just all of a sudden find their was
they are responsible for these children
and they don't have resources
i think we know that a lot of grand
families
um they struggle financially and they
need help
and so one of the things that i'd like
to see this commission do
is to make stronger ties with the
non-profit community
to help grand families uh be successful
in in taking care of their children
thank you no that's great all set thank
you senator
um thank you very much mr chairman good
just
good to talk to you uh we will circle
back to
uh senator perkins polka to part two
i had a quick question for you if you
don't mind
not at all first off my um my clerk had
asked if you
had written testimony it appeared that
you were
um reading from a script and wondered if
that was something that we could have
file uh sure i did write something out
to read
this morning yep i'm happy to share that
um
i had a quick question on senate bill 43
the the predecessor to this uh this
legislation
was that was that also set up as a
commission
okay it was a commission yep and um
and members of nhhfa
and osi were um pretty key in making it
function
yep and did that um did that
that submitted a report um were any of
the report
uh findings uh did that culminate in any
kind of legislation
uh yes sir uh there was a final report
and actually another one of my pieces of
legislation was the primary finding of
that report which was
um to reinstitute and to statute the
housing and conservation planning
program
and so i actually had a house hearing on
that
yesterday that was voted out of the
um and that's that is a senate bill
that was do you know the number on this
um
sb 86 sir
thank you yes
um anyone else in the committee room
have
questions for senator perkins polka
uh seeing none just thumbs up you must
have done a wonderful job
[Laughter]
well thank you chairman if anything
comes up please feel free to reach out
anytime thank you very much
um is there anyone
with their hands raised for testimony at
this point for
anything i don't know ben frost
okay mr frost
good morning mr chairman thank you for
uh giving me a moment to speak to your
committee
and ben frost i'm the managing director
of the new hampshire
housing finance authority um and i want
to speak to
part two of the bill regarding uh as
rebecca as
senator perkins croker indicated
regarding the um
the the density commission as we called
it this was a really
active commission that was created by
the legislature a couple of years ago
and i had the pleasure of serving as its
clerk
for that period if you go to the
commission's legislative website you'll
see
the extensive reports that were made to
the the commission this is the sb 43
commission
and the findings of the commission both
the interim and the final report
of that commission are all available uh
it was a
an extraordinarily active and productive
uh commission and it simply
because of like so many other parts of
our lives running into covet ran out of
time
um and notwithstanding uh really valiant
effort last fall
uh meeting on a weekly basis we were
simply unable to get through
uh the extensive uh statutory purpose
purposes for which the commission was
created so we asked uh your indulgence
to
re-establish the commission and
certainly uh if if you have any uh
any questions um about the the activity
of the commission
uh representative tom dolan chairman of
the house municipal and county
government committee was a very active
member of it and i would urge you to
speak with him as well i'd be happy to
take any questions
thank you um are there any questions
any on zoom seeing none
right now we're going back to one i'm
assuming
the chair yeah sure the chair will call
john mcallister if you're still
available
good morning mr chair and the honourable
members of the committee thank you for
allowing me the opportunity to testify
i will be testifying in support of
senate bill 142 which is part one
of this bill for the record my name is
john mcallister and i serve as the
secretary
treasurer of the professional
firefighters of new hampshire and have
been a firefighter with the city of
nashua for the past 22 years
we have submitted written testimony so i
will keep my remarks short on this
the professional firefighters of new
hampshire is a state association
representing 42 local unions and
approximately
two thousand active and retired
professional firefighters and
paramedics across the granite state as a
preeminent firefighter
organization in new hampshire we
advocate for the health and safety of
the brave men and women that protect the
citizens of this great state
in the fire service we are routinely
called the scenes of catastrophic
incidents involving severe injuries
tragic loss of human life and property
loss
it is well documented that the
cumulative effects of these exposures
may result in psychological injuries or
even suicide
and it is because of this that i testify
before you today in support of senate
bill
142 relative to the commission to study
post-traumatic stress
disorders and first responders
when we consider the modern day risks of
our firefighters facing
including cancer exposure heart and lung
disease and repeated injury as a result
of physical strain and emotional stress
studying the behavioral health and
wellness of firefighters becomes
increasingly more critical
the commission to study post-traumatic
stress disorder and first responders did
amazing work in the last session however
there is far more work to be done to
determine how we can
combat this occupational illness
as such the professional firefighters of
new hampshire urge the committee's full
support of senate bill 142.
i thank you for the opportunity to
testify this morning and i am happy to
answer any questions that the committee
may have
thank you mr mcallister are there any
questions from
the committee any
on participants from zoom have questions
seeing none that dog hasn't moved on
zoom since the entire time that we've
been sitting here
yeah yeah um
thank you uh mr mcallister i appreciate
your testimony
um i guess
alyssa are you available
police it looks like it's alyssa mr
chairman
okay i apologize that's all right we're
not sure
what what part of senate bill 142 you
would like to testify
on however i would like to testify in
favor of part two regarding the
commission to study barriers to increase
land development in new hampshire mr
chairman
um
thank you very much um for the record my
name is alyssa margalin i serve as
director
of housing action new hampshire we're a
statewide coalition
of 80 organizations our members are
those who
develop manage finance affordable
housing
homeless service providers public
housing agencies
a low-income family and children's
advocates
we're very pleased to support the
part two of senate bill 142
we have played an active role on the
study commission
we have been represented by one of our
members
and leaders in our steering committee
keith tebow
who handles development for southwestern
community services
and is very familiar with issues
concerning
land use uh density uh water
so sewer infrastructure and we agree as
noted earlier
by mr frost that the work has been rich
a little bit more time to help inform
all of us who are working to address
our state's affordable housing crisis
and we urge you to support this part of
the bill
thank you and i'm happy to take any
questions
thank you um are there any questions
from anyone in
the committee room no anyone on zoom
wanting to
no it looks like you're good to go you
did a great job thank you very much for
taking the time and for your patience
are there any other hands raised
i see none um with that i would like to
close the hearing on senate bill 142.
done um
representative wall yes you had a
suggestion
um i
my suggestion was that we have
excuse me discussion as a whole for the
whole committee
rather than break up into caucuses
because there's so much here
and um thinking of what
former chairman pinch said in honor of
him
and they're on the system that we had
back in judiciary uh
uh clear i was going to call you senator
roulard
i'm going to do it again but have an
open discussion for the committee as a
whole
almost as a work session rather as a
work session yes as opposed to breaking
up into caucuses
i think it would be more efficient more
effective and i think we could iron out
our questions more readily that way
well it um thank you uh i
i don't disagree with you at all um it
is
11 o'clock um
we own the room for the day um what i
would
like to suggest is that we
um create something of a work session
here
of the entire committee and
and discuss um if there are
pieces of information that um
committee members would or would like to
have
and and give us some time there
um i'll let you in on a little secret i
plan on
submitting tomorrow to the calendar
an executive session announcement for
next thursday a week from this thursday
so that would give us a time for
um possible amendments to be put
together
um gives us a a week and
a week and a day right or we can two
days
um so i'm perfectly
willing to unmute anyone that
uh has comments or questions or
um or thoughts about either of these two
bills and
thank goodness we don't have eight or
ten of these
omnibus bills quite frankly so
um if anyone has
comments to make or questions they have
about
any of this the we have six
seven eight nine nine parts to this um
i'm happy to entertain them if we need
this would be a good time to discuss
something if we need
um pam to research something for us
in any of those parts um are we gonna
take them in order right now from
do sp 100 and then sp 142 or i think
it's a free-for-all
in this in this group um if you have
something
uh representative um just tell us what
what part you want to talk about and go
okay well i um it's a little unusual i'm
usually used to going to caucus and then
going to this but um
on my behalf i think you know there are
certainly a lot of
great points to 142 um
and that's you know i support i think
all
three of them all three parts of it um
[Music]
so i mean i think housing is an
important issue
i think you know making sure we take
care of our first responders
um especially as they're going through
you know so much
uh ptsd uh post-traumatic stresses
and then i think um do like you know
i believe that foster parents have an
important role or sorry not um
grandparents have an important role to
play during the opioid crisis as we
start you know
as we work to to figure you know
how we can take care of our kids who are
who are affected by this so
i you know i have no problems at all
with actually with 142.
um i'm very happy with 142. sb 100 is a
different story and
i think that one for me is much more of
okay are there are there any pieces
of information um on senate bill 100
that you still
need to uh that are
that we don't have in testimony are
there
other items that you're looking for in
order to
help your thought process on senate bill
and i think the um
the items around i don't mean to put you
on the spot here
you know you're fine um i think the
issue of like i think what was that part
let me just pull it up i think it was
part one um
part two i want to say but the issues
around
um the pilots yeah
that was kind of a little i mean i
understand the study
part of it but i just think that there
is i have some reservations around it
okay anyone else have
thoughts on either of these is that um
representative wall you would you
brought this up is there something that
you
uh um well do i have to push this button
still
i i think for them i don't know can you
rip me over there
can the people on zoom here yep okay
yeah i think you're good
okay um i have some concerns about
so many commissions as opposed to study
committees
um we were advised a few years ago that
commissions were taking up too much time
for outside
members for example for people from the
state agencies and departments taking
them away from their own
jobs and that study committees were much
more
advisable because every single one of
these people
that is list who is listed could very
well come in and testify
at any time the committee would need
them to but wouldn't have to be there as
a commission member
um as commission members i don't know
for sure if they would have voting
rights i mean
really and truly the purpose of these
commissions and committees is to have
further legislation to resolve specific
problems that come out of the
information
that's garnered from all this work and
they will be a lot of work
however looking at the dockets on both
of these
senate bill 100 and senate bill 142
even with amendment they passed the
senate unanimously on roll call votes
so i'm i'm shifting my position a little
bit from saying i really really prefer
study committees which i do to say
these commissions are set up pretty well
and since the senate is fully committed
100 percent to working on these which is
a rarity
um i'm i'm more in support of going with
the commission concepts and not and not
targeting them to try to alter them and
i um just to
just to branch off a little bit from
from i too have always had an aversion
to commissions
first of all and i've had a aversion to
committees second of all um
and and i've had aversions or kind of
um snicker up my sleeve here when i see
two senators showing up at a
uh at a commission um i think that's so
that
they have a better shot at getting one
of them to show up at a
at a commission quite frankly um they
are
they're notoriously not um
great at attendance but um but i also
have some
questions about um well i guess it's the
more so i'll use as an example the
commission on the on the grand families
that goes out five years um
how do you and and
what happens if you're no longer
a representative or a senator in that
time period
um where is the where's the substitution
scheme and all of that i don't i don't
know how that works
go it doesn't
and the thing is we can't commit future
legislatures
we just can't so we would have to alter
the deadlines for reporting purposes
in order to make anything like that work
however that particular one is a very
very important one
i still think that if they get to work
and get the job done
say by whatever the reporting today
would be november 1 or something this
year
um then i could support that but
extending it a number of years is way
too long and
actually if we have a reporting date say
november one of this year just as
for example um we can always extend it
to the second year because we have
another year left
but i don't want to extend it beyond
there at all
i think that goes out to 2020
26. i have a question so janet you're
you're suggesting that november 1st 2022
as the end as the end i see okay
i i that's not a bad idea
what do you think about that um i
i mentioned what my concern is i just
don't know how you
have any idea what this commission would
look like um
it's a crap shoot you anyone else up
comment
and sherry are have been very quiet
today i don't
know if they're really even there quite
frankly um
i am absolutely here i just don't really
have anything
pertinent to add okay all right
um it um
it seems that um aside from this the
timing
um do we have uh do we have
similar thoughts about commissions
i don't know is that is that what mass
is hearing
i prefer committees to commissions i
think the grand families commission
though
would be an exception i think they have
looked at a lot of stuff and they
probably will continue
to look at a lot of stuff we haven't
heard anything about
changing the committee makeup and
testimony today
on the grand families at all we did hear
through private through conversations
about um
one or two changes in the membership and
the membership okay
that's the other part of this i don't
remember which one of these
but there was something like 26 people
on how do you how do you get anything
done with 26 people
yes history shows that here in the
legislature uh that it doesn't work and
i can go back to when we first
established
the right to know commission excuse me
again i apologize for
being hoarse it must be the work being
done outside but anyway um
it doesn't work and when you have a
commission that
size and you say the quorum has to be
seven people or eight people
then what's the point in having such a
huge commission in the first place
especially when they are able to
bring in anyone that they want um
i'm not sure i'm not sure the purpose um
anyway that's just my thought and mr
chairman
if i may please um again it's the
legislators the senators and the state
reps who have
the ability to draft legislation and all
uh they need
information from these other very
important sources
but again i i strongly support calling
these people in
and letting the real workers um
the real uh ones who have to draft the
legislation and all and work with it
straight and follow through
to be the ones who will be serving and
that's
that's why i lean more towards i study
committees on very important subjects if
we have to have something like that at
all
um not as a result not not to
not to pre-judge or determine what
what's going to come out of any of these
committees or where
we're only charged here to determine
whether there will be such a committee
or commission
but i still have doubts in my mind
what can be done about some of these
things um
you know studying the workplace safety
in healthcare city
i'll bring that up for one
i'm not sure there is a law that we can
that we can impose or or
strengthen that helps that
but again we're not the ones that
determine that we're only determining
whether a commission
exists or not to study that i
it just some things i just i'm not sure
it's that same phrase you know it's hard
to legislate
morality there's other things that it's
hard to legislate safety
um you can increase the penalty but it
doesn't necessarily
mean it's going to make things any safer
anyway that's just
exactly and i'm not trying to
predetermine
any outcome for any of these because
there's an
awful lot of work to be done on all the
issues but
we have osha that oversees uh workplace
now we have say hospitals have their own
committees
to deal with safety most organizations
even small businesses often have their
own safety standards that they develop
based on what their own needs are what
their capabilities are
so and again i'm not trying to determine
anything but
again how many people do we need to work
on a particular issue
okay man i'm sorry i didn't see your
hand oh it's that's why
it's in the shadow of the wall behind
you
it's okay um just i mean i think
for me the reason so these commissions a
lot of the people who testified
for the folk for the commissions were
the people who were being asked to be
put on these commissions
um so i think you know for
um there was no major backlash i think a
lot of the people who
didn't want like like you know i think
the people who were
were supportive of these commissions or
people who were being asked to be put on
these commissions so
that's why i um i mean if they if they
want to spend their time like if the new
hampshire hospital association wants to
get together with everybody like i think
i think that's that's i think that's a
that's up to them like the firefighters
want to get together that's good but
um i have like so i have nothing against
that
you muted yourself tim i did it
that was my bad sorry so
you know we're we're stuck in this weird
spot with these omnibus bills that um
unlike some of the omnibus bills and
other committees um the the various
sections of these bills really have
absolutely nothing to do with each other
you know these are
these are study committees and
commissions dealing with entirely
different
subject matter with entirely different
compositions
um you you alluded mr chairman you know
that there
there'd probably be an amendment or two
i
i'm i'm torn on this because i think
that um
i don't know what could be arranged in
advance but
i would i would really love to see if we
could
plan logistically like at the executive
session
to take you know to maybe begin and i'm
just i'm just throwing an idea out
you know to see what comes of it to
maybe take like an
informal pull of what sections
of which of the bills the committee
supported and then have someone run down
to ols
and come back with an amendment that you
know removes the parts that didn't have
the
the support of a majority of the
committee and just have like
you know a committee consensus amendment
because
i'd hate to see um you know i'd hate to
see one of the
one of the bills fail entirely
because a small number of us had an
objection with
one part of these unrelated sections and
it was enough to tip
you know a vote one way or the other um
and i i realized you know with the covet
and the the way that the senate did
their business and sending us these
omnibus bills it's very unfair to the
legislation
um to to put us in the position we're in
of having a vote on the entire bill
i'd i'd love if we can find some way you
know to divide the question out
that would that would fit logistically
with the amendment process
just throwing the idea out there no i
think that's a great idea and one thing
that i'll
add as a as a
comment is that anything that gets
removed from these by amendments
would seem to me uh be fair game
to return again next year without
violating
our house rules um
yeah i would tend to agree with that and
of course
anything we do to amend this is going to
cast this right into a committee of
conference
so there's a chance that anything could
be put right back
in again even if we choose to remove it
in the committee of conference
but i think it's all fair game i i don't
think
i have a feeling and i could be dead
wrong but i have the feeling the
committee as a whole
would like to pass these in some form
but the question one of the basic
questions is do we want a commission
do we want a committee and what do we
want it to really accomplish um i
i don't want to pick apart too much of
what they've done but uh
tim you bring up some really good points
we ought to take what we feel is
workable
and what we don't see is really
something we
have control over or can actually amend
in any way then
we need to eliminate that um i will say
that
the senate's been generous in this they
they've they haven't asked for any
committee members from alleged
administration to be on any of these
they're smart so it's always easier to
uh to volunteer someone else is that
what you're saying
very smart otherwise it would be an itl
the other
uh the other thing that kind of
concerned me and this was
right back to day one when these were
assigned to our committee is
we we have aside from the testimony that
we've had today
we have no purpose statements
no you know what's what's the need
for this you know what's the
yeah go ahead some of them just call for
a report without specifying
what the duties are yeah
i so in
in in response to to
tim's comment that it's not doing a
service
to the to the legislation
they actually didn't give us any
everything
to work with to make the decision if you
want to look at it from that perspective
as well i mean
there's um you know not to pick on the
grand family's
piece but we don't know anything about
um this committee doesn't know anything
about the
the situation with grand families other
than what we were heard today in
testimony
um there's been no statistics shown
of of the growing need for that i mean
we know it maybe
intuitively but but it um
in all of these it's just we want to
create this
the commission because it's important
but right
but there's no um they're there
there's there's no backup purpose yeah
ah i have a question yeah
oh sorry hold on we've got senator
roulard over here
elevate it again um i i
i'm totally with you with why we're
doing all this and taking a look and
doing a poll as to where we're headed
with it
um i kind of
liked the pilot bill i didn't before the
hearing so i found
information that came in on that that
maybe is a good idea i mean i'm not i
don't know a whole lot about it i went
the other way and he was though he went
like he was part now he's against it so
there you go so i think it's a great
idea
to go through some of this to see yay or
nay where you're thinking
whether it should be yay or nay and
whether it should be a committee versus
a commission
i think that perhaps is the second part
of what we need to do
um and as you know janet says do we
want to end the commission on grand
families november 2022
it seems like they've already had a
commission for five years they've done
some
great work um the stuff that was sent to
us by pam
was amazing it's online from department
of health and human services maybe a way
they can work on a way to make sure
people that don't have
access to the internet or whatever a way
to
forward that information to the grand
families maybe
that's an important thing um to work on
that i mean uh
or maybe a contact person just for grand
families the department of health and
human services
i mean that kind of thing i would like
to see i thought sharon carson did a
really good job
outlining what she wanted in this and so
that was really a good
good thing so i think it's a good idea
let's take a little bit of
how we want to do it and whether it
should be a commission or a committee
and kind of go that way or even change
part of whatever it is we want i mean i
don't know
but i like that idea before i go any
further
we need to introduce our new um
can't hear you you need to unmute
yourself
there i am i'm just trying to get my
full picture hold on
well i can't even see it anymore can you
see me
there we go welcome to legislative
administration
thanks for having me where were you
highway and transportation oh okay
and again 23 members i was lost in
translation
yeah too many okay so
you're you you're
agreeing with the idea of having a huge
commission may not be as productive
correct so i was just absorbing
everything everybody had to say today
you're from salem district 8 salem new
hampshire
well welcome to legislative
administration we're kind of an informal
group because we're a smaller group
for the most part we've known each other
for years
and have the ch the ch there's about
six people on this that could be the
chairman is the way i look at it
so including senator ruler
but um but i think we are um
we're looking forward to your input from
uh
from outside so thanks yeah well i'm
excited thank you
thank you for having me in your
committee so late in the year but i'm
here to help and make a difference
excellent um that's what we need a
difference
um yeah so are there any other comments
about any
pieces of this that i didn't hear in
any of the comments things that
additional pieces of information or let
or or work that we can
shove pam's way
that we need to make a decision oh and i
did see
um manny's hand is still up sorry no
you're good thank you mr chair um i just
i just you know for me
at least with 142 i know that um
at the firefighters like or at least not
the firefighters but the first
responders they would like to study this
like you know in that commission so that
they could because i think that they
have some ideas about legislation but
they actually want to
do the due diligence um because it is
you know i think when we're dealing with
because
this the idea of this bill came through
when i was in labor
this was something that they were really
really working on and they just wanted
they wanted to do the due diligence
before making you know because workers
comp is a big
it's a big deal so um they wanted to
just do their due diligence so i think
that's
like like i said i support i think all
three parts of 142
um and so that's that's why i think that
commission was
was important for them let me ask you a
question do you have
any concern about um
a possible 28a issue on this mental
yes i mean
i personally i would let me let me i
would
let me take a look real quick but i
would all right i don't want to put you
on the spot i'm just
i'm just suggesting that um
yeah i'm just i had not thought of that
but i'm thinking
um people who come from small
communities for example
um a lot of yeah a lot of people
a lot of small towns don't have the
funds to train
their first responders their police and
their firefighters
in fact they have volunteers or part
volunteers in the fire department
and part-time police officers only and
so budgets are very very limited i had
not thought of that but that could be an
issue
this is really if you take both bills
this is the only part
that is unrelated this is
this is actually doing something rather
than
studying something um so
[Music]
i i would be
open to removing that
training for that reason
actually mr chairman uh that could come
in as a separate bill next year yeah
anything we remove i'm thinking of the
suicide and insurance payments
i think in the past years ago we had
some type of
legislation along those lines
for police officers um i could be wrong
but
something's stirring in the back back of
my brain on that
that could be separate legislation if it
yep the crickets have arrived um
i think tim tim go ahead
yeah i'd also throw out there um
you know i realize we're kind of
thinking a little far ahead at this
point but the way that the
the bills are structured um
lend themselves very well to being
divisible
on the floor so if if we
find ourselves in the position where for
whatever reason
you know logistics of of a committee
amendment
won't permit us to do what we want to do
um
personally i think it would be entirely
appropriate
if if one of these omnibus bills
found its way to the floor with a
recommendation
in the blurb that you know the question
be divided
to take up like the
the training portion separately because
it's completely unrelated
and like structured differently from
from the other stuff
um i just you know just the the
direction my brain is going i hate to
see
a piece of legislation
fail because of like one section
that wasn't even important to the rest
of the legislation had
trouble or a piece of bad legislation
pass or you know because it was dragged
along as part of a larger bill that
everybody else
wanted and i i think that the way that
these omnibus bills are structured it
makes it very easy for us
um as a committee and for the house you
know to to kind of carve out portions
that we might not want to retain
um i'm not sure mr chairman maybe it's
something for
for you to to speak with um speaker
packard about and see what he will allow
um in terms of like the committee
process for it or something but
i i'm just very uncomfortable um
with having these particular types of
things lumped together into one bill
no argument there i also think we have
that
uh fallback that catch-all of
um this having to go back to the senate
uh where they can non-concur and and we
can maybe
put something together in a committee of
conference over
over an issue like that well maybe uh
maybe we'll be lucky and for the first
time in new hampshire history the senate
will just simply
concur with our amendment with no
discussion
you know well um
so that actually brings up the fact that
this is a very hard thing to schedule
as you can see i screwed up and and
missed by a half an hour
but it is the senate if you
went back to watch the senate hearings
on these
there was very little um testimony yeah
we had we had quite a bit but
um there was almost none in the senate
so i'm not really sure how
strong strongly supported these are
even in the senate i i i mean i know the
vote came out that way but that's pretty
easy pushing you know just saying hi but
yeah i don't know um i wonder
you've missed the deadline for
scheduling for next week no
oh okay i thought you said you missed it
by half an hour no no no i missed the
scheduling when i was
so what what tim said about uh dividing
this bill um and disposing of what we
don't need and what we don't think is
appropriate
um i believe we can do that on this it's
a regular bill that's each or it's
regular that we can
amend it any way we want and
i say we should follow through with the
process um figure out what we want what
we don't want
exec on when we have our next session
again
and let the chips fall where they matter
i think thursday's going to be a long
morning if anything it may be it may be
something that we're able to schedule in
the morning
work out the framework of of our general
agreement
and then go have lunch and send uh
send everything to ols to
let us come back and vote on it in the
afternoon does that sound
i see tim shaking his head yes or
nodding his head yes and mr chairman the
way i'm looking at it um i think it's
wholesome the way we're all discussing
it so that
because otherwise we could go on for
weeks
we had 25 more people yeah
well it's a lot easier doug's not here
you can tell him
you can tell him that um so what uh
what um he was the first name i came up
with oh matt i could have used math
but
so why don't you start thinking about
and we'll shut this off here
but why don't we try to think of the
things that
you have to have absolutely like want to
have
everything that um has okay to have
and then things that absolutely can go
away and it wouldn't break your heart
and then we'll come back with that list
i would like to get
an understanding of whether or not we
think commissions
well that's a fundamental i i got that
that it really is do we want to have
commissions or committees because to me
if we have committees that may change my
whole perspective on whether or not i'm
going to be in favor of something or not
just for the new folks if there are any
that just means that we would be taking
only legislators would be on committees
commissions would have everyone else but
committees can certainly
uh request the input from anyone
they choose you have hearings yep
so um i that that wouldn't bother me
um right again i
told you my priority list i don't like
commissions most of all i
don't like committees second and
uh so i don't know
all right and i really don't think we
should have it go to the floor to divide
the question
i think the question should be divided
right here i think we should be dividing
the question
not a whole house we can't hurt it
we've got it i think we should divide
the question and say
yay to the separate legislation
yay and nay just kind of go from there
and put that forward so
they're not going to know people aren't
going to know what we heard
here today or did not hear for that
matter right
yeah i think the the ideal situation um
on on legislation like this um is
exactly that to come forward you know
with a consensus amendment
um that even if it's not unanimous you
know that they that the committee can
agree
this was the consensus of the committee
with this weird omnibus bill
i mean i i think mr chairman your
suggestion of um
you know giving ols a heads up and
having someone go down there during the
lunch break
to to craft an amendment based on what's
discussed
you know with the executive session is
then then it shall be done um so
so give it some strong thought and then
we'll
uh be prepared to come in next thursday
with um with your
thoughts good okay
yeah final final bit of business not
regarding this at all
um we've gotten word that um douglas
was hospitalized a little bit last week
and if you could just send him some good
well wishes he'll be okay
but he needs a couple weeks to get his
sea legs under him again as we would say
on the coast
so um just send some good wishes to doug
and hope he'll be well soon thank you
will
will he remain his duties and
well the fact that this is a hearing i
guess didn't matter but
i i heard i heard nothing from anyone
that he would not be here so
okay well um good luck doug hope maybe
you're listening
good luck um anything else anyone has
before i
shut you all off i would just
add mr chairman as you're if you're
planning your your next meeting that
um i would be happy to communicate with
ols
after you have a executive session
discussion about how to craft the
amendment and i would think
you know i'll touch base with them today
but i think they'll they're going to
need at least an hour even for a simple
amendment and so um just to
keep that in your minds i don't
i don't anticipate a complicated
amendment um
you know i anything more than remove
section
such and such and or had two members
uh and or this is a committee not a
commission
i mean i i don't i don't anticipate
anything more
complicated than that um i understand
but there there's
a lot of you know a lot of committees
are executing and i just would hate to
yes you know um you know as i said i'll
give them a heads up and
and and do my best but and i think
it needs to be done electronically
they're they're
mostly working remotely so
um you know the system exists and then
you know we can we can do it i just
would hate to have you expect it to be
super fast it might be a longer lunch
than i eat
that's right just as everybody is
thinking about next thursday i wanted to
throw that out
okay thank you very much pam um
anyone else before we close this out